this is your first like big movie like
this
what was it actually like to make versus
what you expected going in
i guess i expected it to be more like a
cheat
you know um like
green screens and
um
[Music]
everything is sort of like fake like i
didn't really expect to be filming a lot
of the stunts i thought it was gonna be
mostly special effects you know um
obviously like i i wanted it to be as
real as possible so then when
when i found out that i do actually get
the chance to like you know perform
these stunts i was stoked and and i feel
like it makes the movie so much better
and so many of the sets were um
[Music]
designed you know like really
intricately and um
there's a lot of
hard work and hours of hours and hours
of
just like tireless
labor that went into building these sets
um
and i think like when you think about it
all like when it stacks up on top of
each other and all of the
the different
minds that went in into it it
the way that it comes together is just
it's
you can't really imagine it you know
it's easier to imagine like a blue
screen or a green screen
um
i think that's probably what shocked me
so much about it was that like it was so
unimaginable
i kind of thought that's how movies were
going to be
that's that's how i thought movies were
made when i was younger you know that's
how i imagined it would be like oh if i
do a big blockbuster movie
they'll be like you know styrofoam sets
and everything looks realistic and
um
[Music]
then i then i thought oh no that's not
realistic but this feels like that i
feel like i'm a kid you know
sure uh did you when you were
auditioning to get this role did you
think you actually had a chance at it or
you sort of like it's just good to put
in you know put you know uh talk to the
casting director you know but you know
what i mean no i had no idea i did not
think i had a chance at all and also it
was one of those like
cycle through you know i was filming
something else in new zealand and so i
would just like
do a bunch of taped auditions at a time
you know so i think it was like one of
like five that i was filming at the time
and then
like obviously you know you just throw
that stuff out there you don't know if
anything's gonna stick and then it did
and i was like this one
like the guest star no but like this big
huge movie
i'm kidding but you know it was such a
crazy
yeah it was crazy i did not expect it
uh i would imagine that there were a lot
of friends and family members that were
incredibly excited you booked this movie
so which one was the one that like
freaked out
probably my brothers like my brothers
are people that are you know they're
just like they're very hard to please
they're very hard to like impress
you know they're your brothers right
they're my younger brothers like they're
just like that like whatever everything
that i've done like whatever
whatever oh i see it i saw you on tv
whatever it doesn't matter um
so that like the fact that this invoked
like any kind of emotion in them in
excitement
at all like that you know you saw
a smidge of a smile and they talk about
it
you know they talk about it
right not even like
i'm so excited they're just like oh yeah
so uncharted and then they they want to
talk about it
which means
they're super stoked plus they play the
games and they're big gamers and stuff
so i already got a rap i'm just going to
say i'm really happy for you and uh
congrats on the movie i hope it's a huge
hit thank you thank you
have a great day you too
you